Big D welcome thank you you're in town
uh here in La you are on tour with Flo
Milly this is your first tour yes how
many dates in are you um 2 dat
10 and I'm having a good time so you
like it so far I do it's hard work it is
I got to wake up early go to bed late do
a lot of time do rehearsal right oh yes
I'm very anal about that we rehearse
every day I was going to say do you have
like a like what's your live show like
do you have dancers do you have yes I
have dancers DJ we go to Whole Nine wow
it's very extravagant so the dancer
thing is is it like do you guys go
through like you f you find out you're
going on tour then you get your dancers
together and you guys get the
choreography popping or like how's that
work I was wondering yeah that's pretty
much how it goes it's like or just like
oh we have this coming up so we're going
to prepare and how we prepare you got
the same crew of dancers always yeah
nice I work with the same Dan um you
just did the BET ciphers too which was
dope yes yes that was really cool it's
always like a I feel like if you're like
a dope rapper like that's one of the
things that like really stamps you every
year for sure you know what I mean for
sure I feel like that [__] is cooler
than the X XXL cover at this point no
disrespect you know oh why you feel like
that I just feel like if you're like a
spitter it's like you know I feel like
the ciphers is what really kind of like
they really put like the real like for
sure a lot of people can't do a ccii
that's okay though right and like on
like sometimes on the XXL like you know
a lot of people can't do the cipher
there but they still do it but like
they're not great at rapping sometimes I
feel like the BT they curate it really
well is what I'm saying bed bars you
know and you're from Brooklyn you better
be able to rap right hey could you
imagine if you were from Brooklyn you
couldn't rap be crazy I don't know it's
like it's in me not on me that is 100%
how long have you been spitting um I've
been rapping seriously for like a year
and a half that's it yeah yeah you
started rapping during Co no after Co so
maybe like a year seriously what yeah
but I've always like written songs
you're like really good thank
you thank you how's that work cuz PE
there's listen I know 45-year-old grown
men grown men MH and they're still
trying I write I wrote Every Day right
every single day and I I was a student I
listened to music listen to who wrote
what found out the production like
really just identified what makes a good
rapper and why who was that that you
were like you know listening to who were
you studying
everybody everybody I listen to my
favorites like I first I identify what I
wanted to sound like what do I why do I
want to rap like what is what's going to
be your message what's going to be your
your impact on hip-hop on female rap on
just being you know creative as
individual um I identified that and then
it was like easy like I know I love Rick
Ross I want to be like a girl Rick Ross
how I do that I'm going to listen to
every single Rick Ross album EP mixtape
every feature everything you know and
just listen to what forwards and
backwards okay what women do I love who
you know what makes them phenomenal
women in music not even just rap you
know right listen to uh Missy Elliot
albums fors and backwards like you know
just
identifying what it is that makes good
music good music and then applying it to
myself so would you say like Rick Ross
and Missy were like the two kind of Rick
Ross and Jay-Z yeah for sure in terms of
like um substance yeah you know what I'm
saying like Rick Ross makes me feel good
um Jay-Z makes me feel good like they're
like perfect rappers in my book I ageart
like Circle it's like five things people
need it's like uh there's like Nas Jay-Z
Rick Ross Benny The Butcher Conway like
the one rap
city inred yeah that's people Eve to me
like it's just certain people that like
has everything rapity don't get enough
flowers cuz she wanted she's she alien
she's crazy word an alien she's an alien
like she's crazy what's your favorite
Rick Ross album oh I can't answer that
question I can't answer that question I
just I can't I feel like Rick Ross
albums are perfect every single one a
couple of them are every single one and
I I see I'm not even going to argue with
you about it that's why I no no tlon
Dawn is a classic Teflon da is a classic
Deeper Than Rap it's my favorite though
but Teflon Dawn and Deeper Than Rap are
my two it's one of them two uh then he
has some like Mastermind was cool like
he's got you know Mastermind is God
forbid God forgives I don't like uh rck
Ross makes great albums self-made uh the
MMG shits were fire no Ross is great
that but my [__] is Rich Forever his
mixtape yeah Rich Forever was crazy Rich
Forever is like Albert Anastasia shout
out to Rose man one of the greatest of
all time I got him in my personal top 10
Rick Ross don't get enough credit
neither I say that all the time he don't
get enough credit that's like he got one
of the smoothest flows ever he's got the
best ear for production ever for sure
and he's [__] Rick Ross Rick Ross is
like he's just so expensive like I
always say Rick R can make you feel like
your 19 uh 92 beater is a rollsroyce new
year like you know what I'm saying like
he just makes you feel so expensive he
Mak you want to get up and stop being
broke it's that beat it's that beat
selection his beat sound it's something
about his voice so powerful yeah
cinematic it's so like he just he
Demands a room he demands attention and
that's like what I want have you had any
any um of your Idols or any of the
people that you studied like reach out
to you or yes Kim
um cardi they're all they're both so
supportive and so so kind and sweet to
me like and their fans are kind of
together yes I've realized that cuz I
said something before about little Kim
that uh people didn't like I didn't even
say anything too crazy but nonetheless I
got the brunt of the fans that were like
they were like queen bees is that what
they call them the be and then the cardi
B fans are and then I'm cool with like
offset and cardi so like then like six
months later I was like I said something
about the song jealousy like I don't
know six months before I came out
because I heard it and then all those
same people who were like threatening to
murder me we like Bole Kev says there's
a new cardan on off I was like good Lord
yo do you have a name for your fans yes
mafian is the mafia o the dinos you know
what I'm saying the Mafia the Mafia the
mob you know are they toxic I don't
think so I I like to tell my fans like
be kind exactly be respectful not even
be kind cuz you don't got to be kind to
people people W [__] with me all right
that's cool but you be respectful we
here for me we W pay attention to
anybody else you know what I'm saying
like support who support me support
everybody until they not supportive and
then it's [__] them some of these toxic
fans I just wonder like who are these
people in real life does that does that
make sense what I'm saying not I'm not
talk about your fans cuz you'll see some
of these fans whether it's like the
little Kim fans or the barbs or just
some of these human beings they say
things on the internet that are so crazy
I just want to know what they do from
like 8:00 p.m. to 4:00 p.m. on a Monday
like what do y'all do in real life
nothing nothing it's just crazy like
toxic did you see that show swarm on
Amazon I did see it I did that show was
crazy crazy ass show what do you watch
on TV what are your go-tos I like like
murder mystery of course you
do is it sexist to say that like why is
that a woman thing like every woman
loves that kind of [__] it might be like
sexist it's a little sexist but it's men
are [__] that's why there it is but
isn't that not true look my wife all her
friends everybody I know they all my my
mom oh my god when my mom and my wife
get together they're just [__] binge
watching serial killer [__] yes I love
it shitty reenactments with shitty
actors oh wow they're interviewing the
the detectives the F it's just yeah I
like stuff like that or I like um I like
this show called sus right now I don't
suits that's got the girl who the the
the uh what's Mega Mar in it right yeah
yes she's phenomenal cuz that's like an
older show that kind of just repoed
right on Netflix it stopped in like 2017
I want to say good though yeah I really
like show like that mhm I like I like
stuff like that suits Gray's Anatomy um
what's the other one um with Matthew
Grey
gobler that I can't think of [__]
sick name right
there I can't think of the show name but
people going did you watch Scandal I
like shows like Scandal Scandal is fire
yeah shout out to her she's she's lovely
sure man what was her name on the show
Olivia Olivia Pope yes the fixer yeah